Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that you can
call if you want to tell me anything we know. If
you have any messages for me, you can call two one
nine two David P. and tell me what's on your mind.
Here's a really, really weird voicemail.
I'm going to play it because it's just
kind of funny and weird. But take a listen.
Speaker 4: Hey, David. Do you believe in birds?
Speaker 1: You know, I do believe in birds.
I've seen birds. I've seen the evidence with
my own eyes. I've spoken to ornithologists who
are confident that birds exist. I've had birds
ravage my backyard garden and I feel very strongly
that birds exist in this world. We have a world
where birds are a part of it, so I don't know what
kind of a strange question. Once I got a question
about whether I believe Africa is real and I do, I
believe Africa is real as well. Strange questions,
but glad to answer them. We have a tremendous
bonus show for you today. Inflation is at its
highest level since 1990. OK, we're going to
keep talking about inflation, and part of that
conversation will continue today. Portugal a great
country. I love Portugal. Portugal has made a law
not about drugs. We've talked about their drug
policy that bans bosses from texting employees
after work. Why and why now? Part of it has to do
with telework and work from home. We will discuss.
And lastly, we now have seen, you know, we
talk about consequences for the for the Trump
riots from January 6th. We now have seen the
longest sentence yet for any of the Trump riders
it was given to Scott Verulam and feds want an
even stricter punishment for the guy known as the
QAnon Shaman. Imagine that two years ago, I didn't
imagine we would be talking about anybody that
goes by the QAnon Shaman, but we are. Feds are
asking for an even longer sentence for the QAnon
Shaman, and we're going to talk about how these
cases are going, how strict are the sentences
and more on today's bonus show. You can sign
up at join Packman dot com. You can use the
coupon code better 21 to get a discount off of
our memberships. We will see you on the bonus
show and live coverage of the Kyle Rittenhouse
trial also continues today on YouTube as well
as on Facebook. We are 27 days from being
back on Twitch. Banned for 30 will be three,
down 27 to go. So just Facebook and YouTube today
for the Kyle Rittenhouse trial. See you then.